they deliberately have a injury
surveillance system that is intended to
fail it was built to fails oh that's the
vaccine adverse event reporting system
which is the system that is a voluntary
system
if you get a vaccine injury your doctor
is supposedly required to report it
but
it's up to him to decide whether it was
a vaccine injury but most doctors don't
want to report it many I mean don't even
know about the system but most of them
don't recognize vaccine injuries
if you die within three months of a
vaccine you should be reported no matter
what you died of
that should be part of the database and
it should be and and under the law if
you're part of a clinical trial
every death during a clinical trial must
be attributed to the intervention unless
proven otherwise so we should have the
same rule that if somebody dies two or
three months after the vaccine it's
assumed to be vaccine related until
proven otherwise
in fact what happens is almost no
vaccine injuries get reported if you're
the doctor yeah
and you tell the patient
or you tell the family this you your dad
needs to get this vaccine
and or he's going to die and they say
well what you know could it hurt him and
he says no it's totally safe it's proven
safe
he gives it to him the father and eyes
17 days later
and other and most deaths 99 of death
there's no autopsy for older people
there's never an autopsy almost never I
thought it cost five thousand dollars
now people aren't going to do it so
the doctor's incentives to say hey no no
I did not kill your father
the vaccine did not kill them right
right people don't use human nature yeah
people die so they don't report it
Affairs nothing gets reported and
actually we've known this for decades
and important people have who are part
of the you know medical
mainstream like David Kessler's former
Surgeon General
I said this this system is completely
broken
as a result of that in 2010
HHS
High a retained or contracted a
sub-agency the agency for healthcare
research HR research quality hrcq
to study the fair system to see how
effective it was and ahrq and develop a
machine counting system
that would not have the defects of a
voluntary system that and so how do you
do that
it's easy to do
you go to the hmos the hmos have all the
vaccine records of every patient they
have all the medical claims and you do
like I said before a cluster analysis
and you get
95 of vaccine injuries are going to
appear on that yeah okay if there's a
vaccine causing diabetes juvenile
diabetes rheumatoid arthritis text or
that's
you will see that so and you can
stratify by age by gender by you know by
in every way and you can figure out
exactly what's causing the problems and
then you can cure it
oh ahr cqs
develop not only studied one of the hmos
an HMO in Boston called Harvard Pilgrim
one of the 10 big ones
they also developed a machine counting
system which they plugged in at Harvard
Pilgrim and what they found was at the
machine counting system was collecting
something like 40 40 times
the number of injuries that 40 to 99
times the number of injuries that the
monetary severe system catches yep and
what they concluded was that
the various system was not just missing
99 of injuries it was missing more than
99 that's how bad it is and
the ah argue the plan was
to roll their machine counting system
out to all the other hmos and as soon as
CDC showed us all that data and so an
injury rate of 2.7 so one in every 40
people who came in to get a vaccine were
suffering
some kind of noteworthy injury
they said we are telling people that
injuries only occur one in a million and
um and they shut not only did they shut
down the whole project
but they stopped answering the phone
calls of their sister agency how do I
know that because hrq did a
peer-reviewed publication anybody can
look it up it's called Lazarus 2010.
and they say in it CDC no longer would
answer our phone calls once we gave them
the data so
Tony fauci knows that system because
he's been told many many times
ad system is on a Shelf at HHS
ready to roll out and if you really
wanted to know whether these vaccines
were injuring people they can do it
overnight and yet he left it there and
left us with the system that he knows
is collecting probably less than one
percent of vaccine injuries so
there's some bad interaction between
Public Health
and medicine medicine being targeted at
helping the individual Public Health
being targeted at the overall rate of
various disorders Public Health
clearly feels entitled to lie right yes
that from the point of view lies it
claims they're Noble lives um those who
look into these lies begin to wonder
what the hell is driving them but
nonetheless because Public Health feels
entitled to lie in order to simplify the
story so that people will for example uh
get vaccinated uh to control a
contagious disease
what it does if you don't take the data
that then allows people to understand
just what the rate of Adverse Events is
is it interrupts informed consent yeah
right your doctor doesn't know how
dangerous what you're being exposed to
is you don't know how dangerous and
therefore your doctor accepting that it
is worth the risk for you and you're
accepting that it is worth the risk for
you is it's something you're not capable
you're not capable of giving your
informed consent because you're
misinformed it's misinformed consent and
so the funny thing funny
there's nothing funny about this but you
say the Veris system is built to fail we
know we know well that it dramatically
under counts is it getting three percent
is it getting ten percent is it getting
one percent we don't know but we know
it's not getting the majority of these
events and yet with these vaccines
there's an off the chart signal an
off-the-charge signal that when it is
called in theirs right inverse the
system that is difficult right despite
the fact that the system is built more
than half of the vaccine deaths
that have occurred since the system was
put in place in 1986 over 40 years
um have occurred in the last since the
roll out of these fact uh coveted
vaccines yeah there's like it's not just
a hockey stick it's a right angle to
earn off the off of the graph yeah no
it's and so that tells you something and
then when that is pointed out to the
authorities what you get back is here
are the reasons that we don't believe
the varis data which even if that was
correct it leaves you with no
understanding of how dangerous this is
it leaves you with no data which does
not it's not the same thing as an
indication that they're safe yeah so the
whole thing
it behaves like something that doesn't
want to know and the fact is when your
health or Worse your children's health
is dependent on some system that claims
to have rendered something safe but is
actively avoiding the information that
would tell you that it had made an error
that is the opposite of safe yeah well
you know and and here's how it kind of
pervasive it is and how it's infiltrated
the media because everybody is part of
this
has been co-opted into this conspiracy
to tell people to Gaslight people who
say that they've been injured to
marginalize them to silence them to
de-platform um you know it's not just me
it was talking about
the generalized risks you know and
talking about science but it's a mother
or a dad or a child who lost a parent
who's as here's what happened when they
got the vaccine as a video of you know
the parent
um going into the seizure with a child
going to the seizures
immediately after vaccination and if you
put that out you will be you will be
disappeared
so when this is early in the pandemic
you know Hank Aaron was part of who I
knew
was part of uh
um of a national campaign because blacks
are very very vaccine resistant a long
history of of mistrust of the medical
establishment and
um and so the CDC was rounding up
several isolators and sports leaders who
are African-American to publicly take
the vaccine so
Hank Aaron went on stage and got the
vaccine at Emory University and then and
17 late days later he dies
and I wrote an article for the defender
for Children's Health offense
and talked about it on my podcast and
um and I said I never said his death was
caused by the vaccine and nobody accused
me of saying that what I said
is that his death was part of a wave of
death or seeing in elderly people
immediately after vaccination which is
completely documented
and I and I was immediately attacked by
the New York Times by USA Today CNN ABC
NBC
thousands of news organizations
literally around the world
who were saying that I was lying and the
New York Times said that
they had spoken to the
um to the uh to the Atlanta
uh corner
and at the Atlanta coroner had told them
that Hank Aaron did not suffer from a
vaccine injury that this was not it was
not vaccine related
so I called The Fulton County coroner
because I I wanted to know what task
they use
to make that determination because you
know mostly
vaccine injuries and deaths don't leave
fingerprints you don't know what the
person I have a heart attack or a stroke
that he would have had anyway whether
the vaccine contributed and I and I was
curious about how they had made such a
how they had such certitude about that
determination
and when I got the corner on the phone
they said to me we never saw Hank
Aaron's body we never performed an
autopsy the family buried that body and
nobody ever did a postmortem on it
and yet the New York Times reported a
lie and there's just this this
incredible impulse in the and you know
when I reported my conversation
it was just silence there was no effort
by the times or any of these other
papers to correct their error
it's uh it's quite extraordinary
at everybody is part of this effort to
make sure that nobody believes that
people believe that vaccines are
completely safe
and completely effective and anybody who
disagrees with that at this you know
punished yeah anybody anybody who asks
questions
is is punished and the punishment
um I think it is largely going to be
invisible to anybody who hasn't been on
the wrong end of it but the punishment
is absolutely ruthless it is gaslighting
and I must say it's not the first time
I've been demonized
um it is the first time I've been
demonized by something that clearly has
a many million dollar budget it is a
whole different experience and
um the idea
that there are
billions I presume hundreds of billions
of dollars at stake in the market for
covid treatments and vaccines and uh
that a cost of doing business would be
uh some number of millions to just
simply demonize those small number of
people who didn't get the memo and
raised obvious questions about all cause
mortality or number needed to treat or
absolute versus relative measures of
Effectiveness right
um you know it of course they're going
to be successful at controlling the
narrative especially when they have
Partners in uh in the tech platforms who
are willing to do their censoring for
them
[Music]
foreign